[Música]
el tribunal supremo de Nueva York que
impuso una multa de 1,6 millones de
dólares a la organización Trump del
expresidente estadounidense se la
declaró culpable de una trama de evasión
fiscal durante años una multa que muchos
consideran como simbólica Tenemos
reporte
un tornado ha dejado cerca de una decena
de muertos y numerosos destrozos en el
estado estadounidense de Alabama las
autoridades han declarado la emergencia
en seis condados la cifra de víctimas
podría ascender
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos pidió a las fuerzas de seguridad
de Perú actuar de forma legal y
proporcional durante las protestas que
suman ya 49 muertos los manifestantes
mantienen exigencias y bloqueos contra
el gobierno especialmente en el sur del
país
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo oceano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Estados Unidos la organización Trump
tendrá que pagar una multa de 1,61
millones de dólares por la trama de
evasión fiscal que operó durante años
así lo determinó un juez del tribunal
supremo de Nueva York que encontró
culpable a la compañía en diciembre
pasado la penalización es la máxima
posible tras los 17 delitos económicos
de los que fue hallada culpable
anteriormente nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Vázquez nos
comentaba por qué esta multa es
considerada por muchos como simbólica
es considerada simbólica porque 1,6
millones de dólares es bastante poco
para una organización acostumbrada a
manejar billones de dólares en Estados
Unidos y lo que dicen ya muchos
analistas es que se va a tener que
revisar la legislación financiera en
Nueva York porque pues en muchas
empresas pues le sale de alguna manera
no tan costoso hacer este tipo de
crímenes Fiscales y crímenes financieros
sí la deuda va a ser de apenas uno coma
seis millones de dólares Esta es la
deuda más alta que se le puede cobrar en
el estado de Nueva York a las
organizaciones en este tipo de crímenes
financieros recordemos que las
organizaciones de Trump fueron ya
hallados culpables de 17 crímenes
financieros entre ellos
falsificar balances financieros y
también fraude fiscal y por eso Entonces
esta multa es considerada simbólica hay
que recordar que la organización de
Trump tendrá 14 días para pagar
multa y que ninguno Ninguno de los
integrantes de la Organización de de
Donald Trump pues irá a la cárcel o
tendrá pues eh consecuencias criminales
personales para los miembros de esta
organización
también en Estados Unidos continúa la
polémica Por un segundo paquete de
documentos clasificados en la residencia
del presidente Joe biden tras el
hallazgo de un primer grupo en sus
antiguas oficinas en noviembre de 2022
los abogados de biden fueron quienes
encontraron los archivos y los
entregaron a las autoridades pero los
republicanos aseguran que no se está
dando el mismo trato que a un caso
similar contra el expresidente Donald
Trump Pese a que este jueves el fiscal
general designó a un fiscal
independiente para investigar el caso
y cerca de una decena de personas
murieron por el Tornado que pasó por el
estado de Alabama destruyendo viviendas
y dejando sin electricidad a miles de
habitantes en el sureste del país la
gobernadora key declaró el estado de
emergencia en seis condados
esto es todo lo que queda de esta casa
después de que un tornado arrasara la
ciudad de Selma en Alabama fuertes
vientos azotaron el jueves al sur de
Estados Unidos dejando territorio
devastados
esto es mucho daño Toda mi casa está
patas arriba tenía una tienda justo ahí
ha desaparecido
varias personas han muerto entre ellas
un niño de 5 años en Georgia cuando un
árbol cayó sobre el coche en el que se
encontraba decenas de casas han quedado
destruidas en todos los estados del sur
al menos 23.000 residentes de Alabama
seguían sin electricidad el viernes por
la mañana mientras los empleadas de las
compañías eléctricas trabajaban para
reparar los daños
la gobernadora del Estado key decretó el
estado de emergencia en los condados más
afectados el vecino estado de Georgia
hizo lo propio y también canceló las
clases en al menos seis condados el
viernes
sabemos de personas que quedaron varadas
y las casas literalmente se derrumbaron
y estaban debajo del sótano y ya sabes
estamos tratando de llegar a personas
así en este momento todavía tenemos
personas desaparecidas que tenemos que
averiguar dónde están y podrían estar
refugiándose en otro lugar
los tornados Siempre han sido habituales
en Estados Unidos Durante los meses
cálidos especialmente en el centro y el
sur del país pero los científicos
afirman que el fenómeno meteorológico
del jueves Es inusualmente dañino para
esta época del año
en Perú la presidenta dinable cambió a
sus ministros de interior trabajo y de
mujer tras aceptar la renuncia de sus
antecesores esto en medio de las
protestas que se extienden especialmente
por la frontera sur del país fronteriza
con Bolivia y que han dejado casi medio
centenar de Muertos al respecto al
relator de la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos recordó las fuerzas de
seguridad del país que deben actuar de
manera legal y proporcional lluís Muñoz
con los detalles
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos concluyó su visita a Perú tras
reunirse con víctimas congresistas y la
presidenta constataron un clima de
extrema polarización y una fuerte
estigmatización étnica y regional
pidieron a la policía de atenerse a los
estandares e interamericanos e hicieron
un llamado lo que estamos instando es a
un diálogo amplio ese diálogo amplio
puede contener acuerdos
y esos acuerdos tienen que originarse de
esa amplia representatividad y tienen
que ser en el marco del Estado de
derecho sin acuerdo político Así se ve
la frontera entre Perú y Bolivia los
manifestantes mantienen los bloqueos y
decenas de camiones llevan 10 días
varados vamos a permanecer Sí o sí acá
hasta que se vaya a la presidenta
Mientras tanto la presidenta Dina
boluarte trata de ganar aire ante la
comunidad internacional en la Cumbre
virtual de la voz del sur global dijo
que su gobierno promueve el diálogo por
la paz y la reconciliación esto en plena
crisis diplomática con México Colombia y
Bolivia y tras recibir un llamado de
atención de chile y Estados Unidos Mira
yo estoy bien preocupado porque
estamos corriendo el riesgo de aislar y
como El Ejecutivo no tiene bancada
parlamentaria no
como no tiene fuerza política ni aparato
político está asumiendo la agenda de
política exterior del Congreso es más de
los sectores más duros del Congreso de
la derecha temporal las protestas
estallaron el ocho de diciembre con el
intento de Pedro castillo de disolver El
Congreso esto derivó en su posterior
encarcelación acusado de darse un
autogolpe de estado los manifestantes se
rebelaron y ahora exigen la renuncia de
la presidenta el cierre del Congreso el
adelanto de elecciones a 2023 y la
convocatoria de una asamblea
Constituyente
nos vamos hasta Brasil la Corte Suprema
del país acordó a petición de la
fiscalía abrir una investigación contra
el expresidente Jair bolsonaro esto por
presuntamente haber alentado a las
protestas antidemocráticas que acabaron
con el asalto a las sedes de los tres
poderes estatales en Brasil y al pasado
domingo se anunció también se pedirá la
orden de extradición contra el ex
ministro de Justicia Anderson Torres si
no vuelve al país antes del lunes
y alrededor de 28.000 armas incautadas
por las fuerzas de seguridad colombianas
fueron fundidas para transformarlas en
Varillas de acero que servirán para la
construcción de viviendas en el
departamento de boyacá en el centro del
país Ramiro cuevasberena nos cuenta más
transformando armas en Esperanza así se
llama la iniciativa de la empresa
productora de acero gardaudiaco que
cuenta con la colaboración del ejército
colombiano más de 28.000 armas
incautadas fueron donadas y fundidas con
la misión de enviar un potente mensaje
modificar los elementos que hacían daños
en las calles en herramientas útiles
son armas que están en poder de
delincuentes de diferentes categorías y
pelambres esas armas hoy se recogen y
una vez fundidas pasan a ser acero de
construcción que se va a llevar parte de
eso a vivienda de interés social
pistolas fusiles ametralladoras y
lanzacohetes entre otro tipo de
armamento son parte del proyecto de la
empresa que apunta a edificar casas en
el departamento de boyacá donde tiene su
sede central tuvimos la oportunidad de
contribuir con con Colombia con la
destrucción de armas que fueron
capturadas por las fuerzas armadas
y donde nosotros transformamos estará
Estas armas en Aceros que nosotros
donamos para construcción de viviendas
para las personas que viven cerca de
nuestra nuestra planta desde 2018 se han
fundido alrededor de 180 mil armas en el
país
el ejército Se comprometió a continuar
colaborando con La Iniciativa con un
único objetivo llevar tranquilidad a la
vida de colombianos
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y Recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web France
24.com
[Música]